oh my god
[Music]
outside
having a guard dog yeah
[Music]
salaam boyz
there we go
what's your i know what is your first
impression of rami
this man is a handsome dude mashallah is
he he's much taller than you expected
right um
yeah well i knew he was 6-2
but
marshall and rami bro vice versa what's
your first impression
one looks so much better in person
masha'allah is a good looking guy
everyone says bro we don't want any
husband
he's slimmer than i thought he'd be oh
yeah yeah he's lean bro he's lean i've
been losing weight he's lean mean bro
what else
well honestly i'm just ecstatic to be
honest
i haven't really capitalized on my
feelings i haven't digested it right now
i'm just happy to hear my shot alone
why don't you guys tell them what's
happening july 1st bro what's going to
start july 1st july 1st we're doing an
in-person podcast only july 1st i mean
july
first one and every single week what are
they gonna get we're gonna get in-person
podcast three of us in person in our
home built studio mashallah
[Laughter]
yeah
yo what does that look like bro there's
like a smile like a little piranha bro
oh no bro did you did you skin this this
fish with your bare hands
yes
yeah
let's see let's see where the meat is
oh
what's like half the meat i already have
there's a lot of buttercream
y'all know caught in 4k broken ice cream
bro oh my god
why can't i lose weight
what's going on man this is the studio
yeah this is the studio bro it's a t3
round table right here
we got our
beautiful beautiful soft lights here
absolutely gorgeous nice to the touch as
well
all right beautiful
focusrite
i8i8 audio interface
we got
our sure
sm7b
how many of these we got we got three of
them bro this is the real deal right
here
sorry bro we got what we got the
gorge [ __ ]
gorge [ __ ]
the name of the boat there you go
oh that one's not connected no it's not
okay i shall
connect
let's get it bro from ball time
let's go
you're thinking what where's your shoes
yo what are those
[Music]
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
brother where are we at
yeah tell them we gotta charge them
extra
hey bro
we taking donations guys this wasn't
easy
yo is this what you're supposed to do uh
first night of nike yeah
[Music]
sometimes harder isn't always better
yo my guy genuine question bro
if i wake up in the middle of the night
and i see this pearl vast looking at me
what do i do
this this pervy ass
with that smile what do i what do i do
bro
shoo you come in this bed with me and
spoon bro damn you like being a little
spoon either that or you better stay
real quiet as i make my way over to your
bed
he is i think three years old turning
three soon
what's he like bro does he like to
cuddle does he not like the cuddle half
half half half yeah he's perfect balance
perfect balance okay yeah he's a good
boy
does he have his nuts still nope
chopped off damn
until next time when you see a second
cat
this bro
bro what are the benefits of uh being
out in the sun
testosterone
what else
vitamin d production
what else what does it do for your
inflammation bro it lowers inflammation
especially if you are grounding at the
same time what is grounding
you literally just
have your feet on earth
[Music]
like whoa
bro i just seen that i was trippy for a
second
what are they looking forward to bro
july 1st what's going on
we are
do you want me to take the assist
yes please
we are dropping our first
in-person podcast
in sha allah
can you show me the the candles papi
ah i thought you
you know
which what which candle
stuck for the love
we got the large for the size queens
the medium for the ones who want just a
nice and
you know just something that they can
handle for the rest of their lives and
then the small ones for the ones who
just
you know they just weren't blessed with
as big of an opening
these are my candle holders yeah yeah of
course
of course exactly what i'm talking about
like a candle on your legs so see
oh
yeah take it all bro
no no take it out so they have a better
idea of what we're talking about so
y'all disgust me
stuck for a lot bro we're leaving
youtube bro screw this
filthy bro
yeah do should we even give them the the
new episodes every single friday bro for
the foreseeable future yeah just all the
passwords okay we'll give that up though
all right inshallah in person us three
new podcasts every single friday same
time as always
for the foreseeable future
if you guys made this for a hashtag size
queen for the big candle holders come on
now salaam alaikum